le réchauffement que l'on pourrait
envisager serait à réchauffement très
faible ce serait soit réchauffement
d'origine naturelle ce serait aussi de
l'ordre de quelques dixièmes de degrés
les conséquences seraient à peine
perceptible même réchauffement si cela
était le cas de deux à trois degrés
centigrades jeu comme à mon sens ça
n'aurait pas une incidence forcément
catastrophique le risque reste je ne
viens pas de tellement du co2 en homme
commence à me casser les oreilles avec
cette histoire de co2 je pense pas que
cela
la cause de ce changement dû aux
dégagements de co2 soit prouvée par
exemple le fait que les courbes
d'augmentation température et de co2
soient parallèles ça s'avère fort
nicolas sarkozy at il changé d'avis sur
le réchauffement climatique
voici la phrase qui fait polémique
prononcé hier devant des entrepreneurs
on parle beaucoup de dérèglement
climatique
mais ça fait 4 5 milliards d'années que
le climat change
l'homme n'est pas le seul responsable de
ce changement
l'environnement une donnée dont donald
trump ne tient pas à s'embarrasser lors
de son mandat preuve de l'orientation
qu'il veut donner à son pays
il a nommé un climato sceptiques à la
tête de l'agencé pour l'environnement et
baisser les budgets de la recherche
une autre de ses bêtes noires la coop 21
la corde paris sur le climat
[Musique]